i'm going to show you another way to
solve this problem
and it's delightful in how succinct it
is but you'd have to think about it
right
and that's why i'm going to show it to
you so this second method is to
employ all the stuff that we know from
graphene
which we've done a lot of it in advance
and extension one right and maybe it's
not obvious to you at all
especially because this whole question
is in integerland
so we don't tend to think about graphing
like continuous curves
and when we're talking about integers
but it doesn't mean you can't use
um what's the word i'm looking for you
can't like what we're doing is proving
something harder
as it were if we're proving something
true for like all real values it's
definitely going to be true for all
integer values because the integers are
a subset
of the real values right so here's
that's all of it let me explain what i
mean okay i want you to think carefully
i'm just going to sort of carry on from
this point right here
this is where i'm going to pick up from
right so i arrived at this statement
and previously i proved that this
couldn't possibly true
be true by looking at the um at the
cases for odd and even
for parody right what i'm going to do is
i'm going to prove that this cannot
possibly be true
but do it from a graphical from a visual
point
of view that's how i'm going to do this
now think about how you might prove that
this
and this can't possibly be true
or be equal rather what does it mean
when you say two things like
this in graphing terms are equal well if
you've got two graphs
and you've got like so here's y equals x
squared and here's y equals 2x right and
you go and you try and equate them
what are you going to find i'd love you
to post it in chat actually it's not
complicated if i had y equals x squared
and y equals two x right and then i said
oh i'm going to put these two together
and try and show
when they're equal if you solve this
thing what are you going to
find like what what uh what do the
solutions to that equation mean in this
context
any takers
all the way back to like year nine yes
thank you sean well done
jiao got in very quickly and well done
and get as well we're going to find the
points of intersection
like we'll factorize we'll get two x
values you put them back in you get two
y values right
so when you have a look at this right
what this is saying is or what i'm
trying to prove is
there's no point of intersection between
these because that's what i said
right here right they can't possibly be
equal to each other that's the
contradiction i was after
so we need to reason through this a
little bit right i'm going to think
about these two
as exponential curves right because
that's what
you know the n is going to be constant
and you're raising it to a power so it
gets bigger and bigger
and that m plus 1 is also constant and
then you raise it to some power
they're both exponential curves but
being that they have different bases
they're going to prove this visually in
a second
they can only intersect once and that's
at their
y-intercept so here are my graphs right
here's my visual argument it has to be
good enough that i can stand on it as my
reasoning yeah
here in green is my first exponential
and i've got this second exponential
which all i know its relationship to the
green one is that it's
going to be steeper over here right um
it's going to have a
larger base so it will grow faster right
over here it's got a larger base so it
shrinks faster as well
exponential decay going in that
direction okay
now hot in a second mr wu you said
the whole point that we're trying to get
toward was that they can't intersect
but you just have shown that they do
intersect right
but can anyone tell me why is this
actually still okay
this is still going to land me on a
legitimate proof even though i have
found an intersection
and i was trying to show that there is
no intersection
okay so anger's got this suggestion
right that now just be careful
right um what are the values that can
change i do have
n being greater than or equal to one but
that just tells me that this is going to
be
increasing rather than like a decay
situation going from left to right okay
what's the problem here well where where
is this true
the answer is it's true when x equals
0 right the coordinates of that spot are
0 comma 1 no matter what the base is
right
but the 0 is this index up here it's
this thing here which
in our original equation has to be
p or q see that so
to get these two things being equal the
only way and this makes sense right if
you've got different bases
the only way for the two things to be
equal is that p and q
both have to be zero okay now
i actually have no problem with p being
zero right
because you can put that in and get
something reasonable but q
have a look at what we wrote down right
in our original assumption
q can't be number one yes thank you for
n they can't be equal to each other but
even like q can't even be zero at all
forget about whether it's equal to p
right q is here in the denominator so it
cannot possibly be equal to zero so
really
i ought to have uh let's see if i can
fix this in an artful way
oops that was way too big uh let's try
this that's better
okay let's punch a hole in it there we
go uh x can't be zero
for that um n plus one to the power of q
curve
uh because then you'd have a q equals
zero on the denominator which is a bit
of a problem right
so therefore here is my um conclusion
oopsie daisy i'm not doing the right
kind of deletion there we go
um the only way that these two things
can be equal
is if and only if p and q are both equal
to zero
as rain already pointed out that's a
problem and this is a problem so you
just got problems going all over which
is
actually kind of what we wanted we
wanted contradictions
so therefore i have what i wanted that
it can't possibly be
the assumption can't possibly be true so
therefore
it's not rational it's irrational
so i hope you sort of gained not just
the solution but the way to think about
it is the key
because that's what you're going to need
to be able to reproduce yourself when
you're like ah
what tools do i have in my toolkit to
solve this question
answer you have a lot now that's the
thing that makes the hsc so hard
um you have all the tools in your
toolbox which is awesome
solve a huge range of problems but also
means you've got to rummage around in
there because there's so many different
tools you can
choose from i bet most of you probably
didn't even think at all about graphing
in the context of this question
but if there's anything that mrs lees
and i have taught you it's that graphing
is awesome
and it's useful in so many different
places especially or even the ones
where you wouldn't expect it